the first four weeks with the hardest
because you you feel kind of helpless
and i was in so much pain if i'm being
honest with you
simon broke his silence to et about his
freak electric bike accident in august
the 61 year old had a six hour surgery
to insert a metal rod in his back
and his recovery has been nothing short
of miraculous just like the doctor said
you hit this kind of seven eight week
mark
and like it's like it never happened i
mean literally like that
one of the things you've got to do is
like so much exercise as you know like
to kind of like heal and everything else
so i have to walk like five ten miles a
day
so i actually feel better than i did a
year ago
simon credits girlfriend lauren and
their seven-year-old son
with helping him heal you are raising
him and you're taking care of eric
he also is taking care of you you've hit
the nail on the head that's exactly what
it was
i was very embarrassed when i got home
from the hospital because i was like the
guy from
up the movie you know like on one of
those walking frames like with the
tennis balls
and i was really embarrassed about it
and he came in because i've got all
these metal rods in my back and screws
and even daddy you're like iron man
aren't you and i went
yeah i'm like iron man yeah and just
four months later
iron man simon was back jet skiing in
barbados
the doctor said to me there's one thing
you cannot do simon
you cannot go jet skiing when you're on
holiday it's like
day two i'm on i was jet skiing again et
was first to reunite the entire agt gang
eager to get back to work with simon in
one piece
is it because you enjoyed missing a half
a season of agt so much and trying to
make another happen
i would have said that i'm not going to
do anything up until the day
i promise you we need you
before the panel reconvenes for season
16 on nbc
agt is giving performers a last chance
to audition
virtually doing this online i feel like
it opens the door to so many people that
we couldn't see before because they
couldn't come
to the audition so i feel like this is
going to be a great year
i'm the only vaccinated uh member that's
true
you're the only old one no you look
younger
what have you had that's a side effect
[Music]
moderna